this is a production of Cornell
University Thank You Vera Tim for that
sensitive question so I will not be
talking about it that then today and
we'll be talking about Sorrell health
which is another very exciting topic and
I'm gonna try to focus on sort of bigger
picture issues because I believe that we
need to understand that in order to be
able to think about how we can sort of
address some of the current issues so
just as a quick introduction and you
know we've talked about soil health in
the past so I'm not gonna go down too
far but it basically relates to
functioning of the soil the capacity to
function kind of like with human health
it's an it's an equivalent and so some
of these functions include supporting
plant growth and thereby crops some of
this being an excellent habitat for
organisms being in a hydrological and
environmental buffer things like that
okay and I often like to start out with
this diagram that sort of shows how we
as humans are impacted by soil health
through maybe two major pathways one is
sort of the agriculture nutrition and
the other one is more the ecosystem
services and the environmental impacts
issues like climate change or water
quality etc today I want to explore a
little bit more how we as humans are
also impacting soil health so the arrow
going the other way so the other thing
that's been really exciting about soil
health and we started a major effort
here at Cornell with Georgia Bobby and
Dave wolf in about 18 years ago I think
it was and what it brought together is
is the the three major supporting
disciplines in soil science and so ended
up working with so chemists worked with
Murray McBride and Hannah and people
like that with Janice T's and now Dan
Buckley they both and Georgia Bobby and
no I really come out of the physical
area but one of the ideas initially was
to say well we really did a very good
job with nutrients in pH or the
the chemical aspects but the physical
and biological aspects are not very well
addressed so that brought us to
developing a soil health test basically
sort of a standard test that's made up
of chemical physical and biological
indicators and these were selected based
on their general utility cost and and
all that and we're now in the soil
health lab in this building we're now
processing several thousands of samples
annually from basically all over the
world and it has sort of become one of
the standards for soil health assessment
and and we've tweaked it a little bit
over the years but they've largely held
up as being really good indicators now
show you some results later on but I
want to start at a very foundational
level first that's really what soils
made up what what makes up soils and and
there's really a few very basic
ingredients that make soil so one is the
minerals typically weathered geological
material biological material and then
water air and Sun as the other major
ingredients and that basically the water
dissolves the mineral of the crystals
and and and and dissolves the minerals
makes nutrients available some of those
nutrients are biologically hydrogen or
lead right you need water air and Sun in
carbon dioxide you need oxygen need
water to grow plants and to have the
plans to feed other organisms etc etc
and let's see sort of what on earth at
least makes the soils very special and
we end up with this sort of accumulation
of carbon and minerals so in the natural
soil formation this is really a very
efficient system most of the minerals
that are being dissolved by chemical
weathering are being absorbed through
roots by plants and then feed other
organisms okay so most of the minerals
dissolved end up actually in some type
of organic material if they're not being
absorbed by the soil but very low loss
great so the organics the carbon eater
builds up in the soil especially here
you see that soil or they're being
recycled
you know either directly plant material
being recycled or recycled through some
other organism okay but in natural
system you basically have an
accumulation over time of minerals and
carbon in the organic matter right and
that sort of creates a you might say a
bank account of stored energy and
minerals so an example of a highly
successful type of soil health formation
are these Pyrrha glacial lusts soils
under grassland vegetation which you
find in sort of lights now you know most
of the Corn Belt lusts Orioles are wind
derived very fresh material from recent
glaciation grassland soils are very
efficient with capturing the energy from
the Sun and the water and then pumping a
lot of carbon into that soil so you get
these very deep mala seeds that are
really you know fantastic as a success
story in terms and around the world we
have a lot of similar soils like that we
know the soils here you know we think of
Iowa and places like that but you know
China and Ukraine Central Europe even in
South America you have similar soils and
believe me a lot of wars have been
fought over controlling those kind of
lands because they are the most
productive soils so if you look at so
this accumulation of minerals and carbon
right and so here the carbon this is
organic sea and the minerals I just show
the phosphorus at least our five soils
in in Indiana it's there both of
publication I like to do some back of
the envelope calculations of what does
this really mean what's in those soils
well there's about 3,000 kilograms of
phosphorus per hectare in the in the top
foot of those soils in terms of
phosphorus that's either in organic form
or some other non crystalline absorb
form
and so for the entire route sound it may
be about double when you think of a corn
and seasonal corn plant requires about
forty to fifty kilograms so you can
think about this being a bank of
minerals that you can draw out of no you
have a good hundred years maybe that you
could draw out of that okay not that we
necessarily want to do that but it's
it's there right so that's why these
soils are productive and have been
relatively productive so as opposed to
those soils we also have what we might
call marginally successful soil health
formation and so this is a Cecil soil
from the southeast in the United States
and most of the minerals have already
been leached out because these are old
soils the remaining minerals are a lot
of iron and aluminum oxides the they
were forests arrived so not that much
organic matter and in fact a lot of it
has been lost through erosion and all
that so this is a nut soil and so you
can map that then you look at a picture
like that EC okay we see that most of
these soils that have a lot of
phosphorus tend to be in these P really
show more northern areas where there's
more organic matter in the soil and and
much poorer in the in the southern areas
with the exception of the Mississippi
River Valley but of course that's the
good stuff that comes down the river
right so we'll come back to that later
so in this of course you can you can
upscale that to a global level we tend
to be blessed with very good soils in
this part of the world and most of the
rest of the world has soils more like
this is a some soils from Brazil and so
you know a lot of not a lot of useful
nutrients also be low organic matter
content so that's when you have a
situation where you can maybe get a
couple of years of crop production out
of them and then you have to abandon the
land which kind of stimulated this whole
idea of shifting cultivation to three
years of crops
30 40 years of putting it back
letting the natural searle forming
processes build a little bit of
fertility and then you have another two
or three years right so it's very
different than the situation in say the
Midwest so and of course we started to
develop these soils agriculture
development so we remove the service
vegetation and so that's some of the
carbon but then also of course we till
the soil we stimulate organic matter
decomposition which is great because it
releases the nutrients but it's not so
great because you're basically drawing
out of your bank accounts right and in
addition we have this physical
degradation of the soil and so your
erosion and all that so not only are you
kind of burning up the organic matter
using the nutrients some of them are
actually physically removed off your
field and ghost's elsewhere okay and
this is much more of a problem in hotter
climates or forced derived soils that
basically aren't that good to start out
with okay so and these soils because
we're growing plants typically when
we're growing crops a lot of times its
annual plants and so a large part of the
year there's no active plant growth and
the snow forming processes are not so
basically we're not using the basic
resources of water Sun and minerals as
sufficiently and we have a lot more
losses right much of the minerals and
energy because of agriculture we removed
them we typically harvest you know fifty
to sixty percent of the biomass and even
more of the minerals we're recycling a
little bit through residues or maybe
manures but a lot of it gets lost and so
we're effectively mining these soils
right that's what I'd recorder has done
and it's results in nutrient and carbon
depletion and like I said basically the
need for this continuous production so
here's some data from Kirsten quartz and
many of you know her she's in the in the
audience is sitting right there she
manages the soil health lab there's also
working on my master's program with
Rebecca Schneider and Steve Morreale
miner
vizor and what she has done is sampled
some soils natural soils as much as
possible Prairie soils in the Western
Corn Belt and then sampling Co sampling
at agricultural sites that were right
nearby kind of a site by side comparison
and this is some very preliminary data
she's doing a lot of sort of health
analyses this is this organic matter and
it shows how much loss of organic matter
that's been in an area that's been in
production maybe for less than 150 years
okay so often you know two three four
percent organic matter losses and this
project is in the context of some work
in China that Rebecca and Steve started
in the area northwestern China where we
in a way have a similar ecological
agricultural environment but many more
years of intensive land degradation
it's really quite extreme and dustbowl
like okay so that brings me to this
issue of the geography and the history
part of my thinking started a few years
ago when I'll refine who got her
master's degree with indeed Martinez and
then worked for me for a year or two or
whatever and so obvious very very smart
lady and so I asked her to do some
statistical analysis so she did some
multivariate work and all that but also
asked her to do a regional comparison of
the soils in our soil health database
from the many thousands of samples that
we had had analyzed and compared those
three regions the Midwest and
mid-atlantic and and so based on what I
just said about soil development and and
why some soils are better than other
ones which one would you expect to have
the best results in terms of soil health
right obviously you would say yeah these
Molly soils very glacial mon-sol's okay
well it's good I didn't bet any money on
that because it turned out to be not the
case
okay this is here these are for fiscal
indicators agriculture AgrAbility
available water capacity and penetration
resistance is a hardness indicator and
for a biological indicators organic
matter active carbon protein and
respiration so organic matter is a
standard indicator active carbon
something that we worked on with a wolf
is an labile carbon indicator protein of
course is protein which honesty's on
that respiration as well and so what you
see so where it's green that means that
that region has statistically higher or
makes more favorable numbers okay so you
see that the more theast in the
mid-atlantic tended to have the best
physical and biological conditions
better than the Midwest the only one
that was good in the Midwest was
available water capacity which has more
to do but the dominant textural class
which is more silt loam and silty clay
loam so this is surprising you look at
organic matter the Midwest had about 3%
and all along the East Coast had about
four percent that's one percent
difference in organic man that's a lot
okay the protein content was about
double only the East Coast so this is
really surprising so why is that why
would you have that because because
conventional theory says it should be
much better okay so but when you think
about this now these were the samples
that came into our lab so not a
stratified sampling scheme or whatever
just whatever came so when you think
about it what comes into a lab from the
Midwest is it's it's associated with
corn and soybean row crop production
what comes into our lab from East Coast
it's more livestock more perennial crops
like alfalfa more organic farms okay so
but this is definitely surprising that
soil health is basically better along
the east coast then in the central part
so that really kind of brought me to
think about this spatial dimension of
soil health right so we tend to think of
soil health and sort of forming factors
as something that happens in situ right
but as it turns out that's a huge
spatial dimension to that and that's
both natural
and anthropogenic processes and we're
gonna explore those basically what it
means is that there are areas of
convergence where the basic soil health
resources which is primarily carbon and
minerals alright are coming together in
some area but they're being lost in an
area of divergence okay
so when we think about historically
where are the areas where crop
domestication occurred and we have had
long and sustained food supplies okay so
and you would basically come up with
this list right we know that's from our
introductory agronomy courses and all
that these are the areas where we had
millennia of population growth and
increased food production how is that
possible
if we only have a limited bank of carbon
and minerals right so what do these
areas have in common
you might ask I did ask that well these
areas of what we might call hydro
biogeochemical convergence areas so I'm
really exploiting the Dictionary of the
Greek language here order by your life
and then geochemical right and so these
are areas in a larger geographic region
a catchment where these resources come
together through natural processes all
right water and whatever comes with
water what's dissolved in it either
coming from the surface or subsurface
ends up converging in streams these
streams converge into rivers these
rivers have flood plains and dealt us
that's where some of this material gets
deposited so the sediment the carbon the
minerals that comes with that are all
being concentrated in a relatively small
area and of course the health of the
soil in that area would then be much
more favorable than what the areas where
it's being lost okay so think about an
erosional process even under natural
conditions what's at the surface is the
best part of the soil and if that gets
lost and you concentrate it somewhere
else
that's very favorable
so when you look at you know
descriptions give carbon and nitrogen
profiles of these a grading soils that
are on the receiving end of this
they have very favorable properties of
course you know oftentimes they're also
physically very favorable because they
tend to be silty title material so one
example of that is of course it's the
lower now Nile Valley we know the
history of that millennia of cultures
and population growth but the catchment
of the Nile really goes from the
Mediterranean all the way down to East
Central Africa and the White Nile and
Northeast Blue Nile and so basically the
resources that come from that gigantic
catchment end up really all
concentrating in the Lower Nile Valley
you get the water you get the carbon you
get the minerals and you have that in an
area that's otherwise an extreme desert
right so you have this localized and we
know from history from even from
scriptures and all that you know what
went on there in that lower Nile Valley
so millennia of sustained populations
okay so a gradient soils continuous
mineral and organic matter additions
food surpluses that developed of course
you know once you kind of figured out
how to use certain plans to make crops
out of them they use em or wheat and all
that that allowed you then for trade
specialization administrative heart
hierarchies armies art you name it and
of course slavery right agriculture as a
very ugly history but slavery but you
know you think about if you bring in
slaves from other areas right you also
need to be able to feed them so you need
to have a pretty good food surplus to be
able to say we're bringing other people
in we're gonna make them do the work so
that we don't have to do it okay and and
we and we feed them okay not really a
great part of our history but it is all
was facilitated by the fact that you had
the sustained ability to create food
what we stand in the fact that there
were famines there were past problems
things like that in part related to
climate flood fluctuations another
interesting example is the value of
Mexico so in central Mexico there is a
basin and there used to be a lake there
that is in a volcanic region now
volcanic areas have naturally very
fertile soil your may thick rock
material and this is a geological Basin
so it doesn't drain to the to the ocean
and so you have a convergence there of
mineral resources that in this case came
to a very large lake and so this with
that you don't have the development of
these organic soils so the minerals fed
the crop the the production of Marsh
plants which then build up and so again
you have a huge bank account of minerals
that are developed over the millennia
now this area is no longer a lake and
it's one of the largest cities in the
world it's Mexico City right and it has
been drained now but naturally in the
earlier years this was the center of not
only crop production but of a very high
civilization right this is an impression
of what the city of Tenochtitlan would
have looked like right in the lake
pyramids and all that and basically the
population was fed from the marshes from
this area which we refer to as the
chinampas so if you have marshland and
you want to put it in production so you
have this wonderful rich soil full of
organic matter and minerals the only
problem is you can't grow so many of the
crops because you have water logging so
what do you do you dig canals and you
take the soil out of one area you keep
it up in another area and now you
mineralized that organic matter because
you oxidize it now and you have the most
productive soil you could ever imagine
okay and so but because these were
marshy area services tremendous Bank
of carbon energy and mineral resources
that that went with that okay and that's
you know sort of got some of the early
crop domestication going here
maize being wash you know that story at
several large cities not only
Tenochtitlan but also Teotihuacan which
you can now visit still it's a beautiful
site if you haven't been there with the
pyramids there tenochitlan is now
downtown Mexico City is like one little
ruin left of that and as an aside of
course the additions population there
the musci cos which a part of the Aztecs
were no-till farmers right they they
didn't have any draught animals or
anything like that and so they they use
planting sticks and they didn't really
do any toilets so they were way ahead of
our time of course when the conquerors
came they said to the indigenous
population you're doing it all wrong you
had to till the soil right and then they
say well we don't have any draught
animals well guess what you know this is
a beautiful mural
by Diego Rivera at the palacio nacional
definitely a place to visit because it
shows again this story
the human factor around agriculture and
and you know how that interrelates with
the natural resources so there are a
number of other biogeochemical
convergent zones that I think are
notable so one is Mesopotamia of course
where the source of the water and the
biogeochemical material is primarily
from the indo-gangetic plain right next
to the orographic the most active region
in the world to Himalayas constant
supply of fresh minerals and carbon
coming out of the mountains into and
then the North China Plain and the
Yangtze River Delta very similarly
so North China Plain is the Yellow River
estuary and so these areas were
continuously flooded the new supply of
minerals and carbon that came from upper
areas of the catchments and so these
became highly populated because there
was the opportunity for for high food
production another interesting example
is the country of Japan so Japan is a
very mountainous country you're mostly
volcanic you know I have quakes all the
time they just had one two weeks ago and
then you have relatively limited areas
here where you have these biogeochemical
convergence areas these are flood plains
or coastal plains and but most of the
country is is very mountainous and so
you can't really grow any crops there
except there may be some tiny little
valleys but so so most of the the land
or that is that can that can produce
crops is very intensively used okay they
don't really have a lot of space they
don't have a corn belt or anything like
that okay and so but again these are
biogeochemical convergent zones and they
allow for a very intensive crop
production and coming back home we have
that here in New York our best soils
here in New York are in places like the
Genesee Valley or to Schoharie Valley or
so these are air these are floodplain
soils they derive the resources from the
entire so some of our best soils are in
the Genesee Valley they can compete with
any soil in Iowa or any other place Ile
Genesee Hamlin these are the soils that
are are the best in the and what is
happening to these ancient
biogeochemical conversion zones well you
know we look at the cities that I'm
listing here that are now in these
highly priced agricultural areas right
so they've become very densely populated
they have the rivers have been
channelized so there's no more natural
flooding because it's terrible flooding
is terrible for the humans but it's good
for it was good for the soil to us one
Dam was built here so the whole idea of
what happened to the lower Nile Valley
that's oh no right Russians built that
in the 1960s but still
very intensive crop production now based
on synthetic inputs and some of the
worst soil health degradation you might
imagine you see now in these areas that
were naturally highly productive so that
brings me to so we talked about job
biogeochemical convergence but us humans
also have a big impact on that so we
might call it anthropogenic biochemical
concentration but one very interesting
example of that is if you go to north
western europe not too far from where I
grew up and you see these Heath areas
with Heath vegetation right so it's
interesting because he is a pioneer
species so this area
what's glaciated and so about ten
thousand years ago we had enough there's
an opportunity for the invasion of
various species so Heath is one of the
first ones but these soils in in most of
these areas are very poor very sandy
maybe more rain out washed whatever and
so a lot of them are pot soils very low
blow inherent fertility but there are
these areas in the landscape typically
around some kind of a settlement maybe a
sheep Arn or farmhouse where you have
these fantastic soils or a deep organic
matter and so that's maybe initially
somewhat puzzling but we call these
source hog and soils or in Germany plug
and ash soils so a plugin is really kind
of like a like a cutting Assad right
that's what that word means so what's
happening there is that so first of all
it's somewhat surprising that you still
have heath vegetation when it's a
pioneer species it would have been taken
over by trees right but what the farmers
did in that area they concentrated the
resources from a large area around there
for their own farmstead okay what what
did they do so you had this the heath
they would cut the sod maybe let's say
10 centimeters it's a full of dense
roots and a little bit of soil material
they would bring that to the
furnish that in fact they you said as
bedding in the sheep barns then they had
a lot of sheep and the Sheep of course
would be grazing all over the place
in the landscape and they would be
eating the vegetation that's sheep
actually eat heath okay and then of
course at night you have to protect the
sheep from the wolf's and the foxes and
all that you bring him into the holding
pen the sheep aren't and they had the
heath sod the plugin as the bedding
material the sheep are there what did
they do at night well one of the things
that they do is they defecate and they
urinate so now you've got this nice
mixture kind of a sort of composted
material you mix it with some of the ash
and maybe char and then you deposit that
onto the soils around the farmstead so
now you had a very productive area
around the farmstead there was basically
the mining of resources from a much
larger area so it's kind of the same
idea this Jew biogeochemical convergence
into a smaller area so it's just human
ingenuity to create the system and we
know that there's other examples of that
many of you are familiar with the Terra
Preta to India soils because Johanna's
layman and his and it's lab team not a
lot of work on that it's a very
interesting paper that just came out
it's actually it's - not 2019 officially
it's just only that compares these soils
and so in Terra Preta in Brazil it's
more the chart it seems to be providing
some stabilization with the plug in
soils it's more the fact that they are
in a more temperate climate and so the
organic matter decomposition this is
lower but you know throughout you know
history there are these examples because
the Terra Preta soils are also basically
an example where people took resources
from a larger area and forests in this
particular case and then they brought
them into a smaller area where they were
able to concentrate those resources
so I'm talking about biogeochemical
convergence and gain areas but of course
they're also also lost areas right so
these are the areas in the catchment
that do not benefit from having carbon
and minerals coming from other areas so
these are the areas that are subject to
erosion and leaching of these minerals
and so these are much more fragile areas
and we've known now know that it's very
difficult to sustain crop production
unless he start out with an fabulously
natural naturally fertile soil like
Kamala soils and in the Midwest so it's
another pattern that has occurred over
the past years past millennium centuries
in early agriculture we had a strong
integration of crops primary producers
animals the primary consumers and humans
right
they lived all in the same year
typically on the same farm we saw with
urbanization we saw a separation of the
crops and the animals from the humans
and so some of the minerals and the
carbon did not get fully recycled but
most of them did get cycled around on a
farm now with the commodification good
turn by the way Peter I like that of
Agriculture we've had a separation
increasing separation of the crops from
the animals from the humans right and
this from a biogeochemical perspective
creates some challenges because now we
have this concentrated livestock areas
in this country and we are in one right
now or right here okay central and
western New York are an epicenter for
dairy production and a lot of the
supplemental grains that come out of the
Midwest that are being fed to these
animals means that there's a surplus of
carbon and minerals in these areas
similarly Idaho California
mara peninsula poultry Northwest
Arkansas and then Eastern Carolina and
Virginia for for hogs these are areas
where where does a lot more animals than
would not normally be fed by the
surrounding areas
so basically what we have is a flow of
minerals and carbon from the central
crop production area in the country to
these primary livestock producing areas
including upstate New York okay
through these crops so when you think of
corn and soybean think of biogeochemical
material think of soil health because
these sort of materials that are fed to
the animals and then come out the other
end and are being used to improve the
quality of the soil so of course we know
from our agronomy history in sort of
science history that we've had some
technological developments over the past
couple hundred years on liebe Klaus
Haber and Bosch and the industrial
capacity after World War Two where we
now basically use synthetic minerals to
kind of resupply the losses that come
from the soil okay if we hadn't done
this we would have really run out of
minerals okay so basically what that's
what this map shows so we're now the
major loss of minerals and carbon is
from the central crop production area
we're shipping phosphorus fertilizer
from Florida Carolinas Tennessee Idaho
places like that and a lot of the
potassium comes from Saskatchewan and a
lot of the nitrogen because its
associated with natural gas comes from
the Gulf area
okay so we're resupplying the lost
minerals by using artificial fertilizer
but what we are not be supplying is the
carbon so there's no biological
component to this we're just we're just
resupplying the the inorganic materials
Selenia end up with a situation like
this so these are just two soil health
test reports that bob diddlebock gave me
one from a midwest grain farm and one
from a a northeast dairy farm and so
here the physical indicators biological
indicators and chemical indicators let's
ignore the chemical because it's all
basically fertilizer and lime but you
can see that you know the physical and
biological indicators of the Midwestern
farm score pretty low I mean it's a lot
of red and and yellow okay and you see
that the Northeast dairy farm is mostly
dark green which means that it's very
good so for these soil health indicators
we're getting very good numbers and
that's of course because there's a lot
of manure in the system and there's not
here what's interesting is the one
that's red is phosphorus on the dairy
farm because we down score when this
phosphorus that levels are excessive
okay so we have a problem with excess
here with the phosphorus how many of you
have seen this map
okay this map should be taught in every
introductory agronomy sustainable
agriculture course in the world
this map shows you the flows of grain
and oilseed crops around the world right
so when you see an arrow here I want you
to imagine that it's a flow of soil
health it's it's a flow of the basic
resources of mineral and carbon that
goes from one place to another right so
where's the where's most of that coming
from the Americas right US Canada Brazil
Argentina right where most of it going
China Japan maybe something to Korea etc
look at the blue arrows which is
soybeans right so if you follow the news
you know that all the trade wars the
Chinese are saying well maybe you want
we don't want to buy your soybeans
anymore so they're probably going to
source it from resilience right so we
export 2/3 of our soybeans and half of
that goes to China so every third row
soybeans that you might see in a field
in Iowa it's gonna go down the
Mississippi River and to Iowa so but
think of that as exporting soil health
as well think of it as as the basic
resources that maintains the health of
the soil are being exported no Japan
here we actually export a lot of corn to
Japan and that is in support of their
dairy industry this is pictured from
Hokkaido sanam where are you you're
gonna probably see this I visited entire
kinoshita my former student there this
summer and you look at these dairy farms
and you know there's three barns there's
probably 120 dollars or something like
that and then you look at the amount of
land that stares like wow how can they
possibly feed this many cows from this
little land well a lot of it gets
imported from the United States so we're
building soil health in Japan okay and
so Hokkaido is here this is where that
picture was taken and keep in mind again
depend very mountainous country and so
these areas that are these naturally
productive areas it's all orbit this is
this is Tokyo
Oklahoma this is Nagoya this is Osaka
it's all organized the Japanese rely
very heavily on the few remaining
agricultural lands and one way they can
kind of facilitate is that by importing
a lot of those grains and thereby
importing schools and Japan it's not the
only one here's Korea my former home
country the Netherlands also import a
lot of lot of grain and so in some of
these countries it's actually a big
problem they have problems with
eutrophication in yes to Ares in their
freshwater resources etc now similarly a
typical organic farm here in upstate New
York is also a biogeochemical convergent
zone because they very heavily rely on
compost the compost is derived from
whatever leaf clippings or whatever from
the from the surrounding region and so
you're basically accumulating that onto
a relatively small area okay and some of
these organic firms are actually
starting to have some problems with high
phosphorus levels well here's an
interesting example of biogeochemical
convergence and it's right here on
campus so this is the plant science
building is a man library so Nina basic
in the Horticulture Department every
year with her class he does kind of a
renovation project right and so some of
the landscaping is just fantastic it's
beautiful but the soil here on campus is
not naturally that fertile and so what
what Nina does is she calls it scoop and
dump you come in you put a lot of
compost on the thrilled and you kind of
mix it in with in with a small excavator
and and then you know you have this
wonderful soil comes out of it so what's
the source of the compost that's being
applied the dining halls here at Cornell
other sources well but list that so the
the food residues so where does that
food come from
well maybe California Idaho Florida
Texas whatever alright so think about
that
that when you look at these little plans
there in front of man library part of
that came from California or Idaho Texas
or place okay we're we're kind of
bringing together these basic resources
of minerals and carbon and putting them
in a place where we would like them to
be right nothing wrong with that
it's just kind of interesting to ponder
that right so we're now talking about
peak phosphorus right so the idea of
peak phosphorus like peak oil it's like
we're gonna be running out of phosphorus
fertilizer now the phosphorus mines in
Florida and Idaho are starting to run
out okay oh this is a problem right
well is it really a problem are we
losing a lot of phosphorus a lot is just
a reallocation problem right so we've
now we're accumulating phosphorus on
farms like here in Central New York or
in Eastern Carolina places like that
right and we're exporting them from
places like Iowa and Illinois
all right so the peak phosphorus problem
is partially the structure of
agriculture right that's kind of what
creates this problem it's not that we're
running out of phosphorus it's just that
we're putting it in places where it's
not great use to us while at the same
time having problems like here algae
growth in a Wasco lake which is just
north of here because we have excess
phosphorus right so one of the things
that I think we need to think about is
like in a way in New York we are on the
receiving end of a lot of great mineral
resources and carbon and all that it's
just we just pack it all into these
livestock based farms most areas where
it's a problem we need to spread that
around the woman okay I just want to
show you a few data results I mean we've
done a lot of research and published a
lot I just wanted to show you to give
you a little bit of an upbeat sort of
into this this is a study from North
Carolina where we collaborated with them
they did the cache test on a study that
involves different tillage practices
from very intense
minimum till and what this shows you
here this is protein and yield they had
16 years of yield data it was a great
data set and it shows you two things one
is that as you reduce tillage you
increase the protein levels kind of
makes sense because protein is a very
labile form of carbon and nitrogen so if
you till this will get very easily
decomposed and so if you don't feel this
early kind of build it up but you also
see that has a very good relationship
with yield right so that's great so you
did that's good news you know so these
are the other indicators that has
significant correlations with yield and
I ranked them protein was highest
organic matter what's the most so you
look at these R squared values this is
from menial by the way and you see the
protein active carbon manganese
respiration had the highest correlations
with yield organic matter was only eight
so total organic matter does not have as
good of a correlation with yield as
these labile sources of organic matter
manganese by the way is involved with
organic matter decomposition through a
redox reaction okay so these are all
associated with biological processes and
labile sources of organic matter Agra
stability is a physical indicator what
we know is strongly related in
biological so we're starting to learn a
lot about soil health and and and and
what are important attributes of soil
health I'm going to skip this because
we're running out of time one of the
show this is a Roley slide we're
starting some work with with Dan Buckley
so they are experts on microbial
community analysis and Roley I think
you've analyzed about five hundred seven
hundred samples or something like that
they're coming to our lab and we take a
little bit and we divert it to the Dan
Buckley's lab and roly's been working on
that this is a very exciting new area
according to Dan you can do these
analyses for less than $20 and I think
this is going to be
important part of the future okay
conclusions natural forces spatially
impact soil health right so lower Nile
Valley indo-gangetic plain but
anthropogenic forces are increasingly
affecting the flow of carbon which is
energy and nutrients okay and it becomes
it's it's almost becoming the dominant
process okay we have localized
concentrations maybe with a small
organic farm or dairy farm and then we
have these regional national and even
global flows of the basic resources
around soil health and so the concept of
regenerative agriculture or regenerative
soil health management basically needs
to recognize that situation so knowing
that okay what are some of the
opportunities what are some of the
challenges so one of them is to use good
agronomic practices like reduced tillage
better rotations cover crops
geographically reintegrating livestock
and cross and also to think more deeply
about harvesting these nutrients in the
organic matter the idea that we have
such a problem with excess nutrients and
carbon on these dairy farms here and
that we have other parts of the state
where the soils are starving for carbon
and nutrients okay
is there something can we be a little
bit more creative about that so maybe
that means processing some of that
manure maybe you know yo.hannes is very
interested in pi realizing or maybe Tora
faction which is drying maybe other ways
to process that manure and make it
logistically feasible to spread these
resources around a little bit so I kind
of wanted to stimulate that kind of
thinking because I think in New York we
have that opportunity to to solve some
of these problems but first you need to
understand
source of that problem right which is
very structural very economically driven
okay with that I already went a little
bit over time so thanks very much so the
question is you know whether anaerobic
digestion impacts or all these these
processes so and I'm not an expert in
that area but basically what you're
trying to do there is is capture some of
the energy as methane which you could
also capture in other ways
pyrolysis you could capture it through
direct questions as many ways ways to do
that um I I think that you know it
doesn't necessarily solve this problem
it is just this it it is a processing of
the manure that still retains the excess
nutrients you reduce the carbon a little
bit but it doesn't necessarily in a
structural way unless you take the
resident residual material and you put
it you take it off the dairy farm or off
twice so in terms of this bigger picture
problem it's not necessarily a solution
that's why I'm saying we need to maybe
think about see a big part of the
problem with manure is the bulkiness
right it's difficult to transfer
transport another issue is sort of
pathogens so if we can kind of address
some of these constraints and we can
find ways to spread it around for
example dry manure would be much easier
to transport over somewhat longer
distances so even if you can get the
manure ten miles out on the arm right it
would do a tremendous amount of benefit
most in terms of reducing the problem on
the livestock farm and helping the land
off the livestock
you know well I mean in a way these are
very gross generalizations right I mean
there there are lots of livestock farms
in the Midwest there's a lot of hog
firms also egg farms consider so it is
it is a gross generalization so the you
know here in the in the Northeast when
we use perennials especially perennial
legumes or maybe even color you know
cover crops are a relatively small
solution to this bigger problem but
they're they're potentially useful so
yes I mean it but but the the legumes
primarily relate to nitrogen and so it
doesn't necessarily relate to the other
but your point is well-taken in that you
know we can grow some of that carbon
here right so and they can grow some of
that carbon in places like Iowa by using
better rotations bringing in cover crops
and all that so you can use those basic
minerals resource even if they're
synthetic and you can still build up
their soils if you use better rotations
and better cropping systems right and so
that's what that's one part of that
solution right yes
I would agree with that we mean the
effects of slavery that happened in the
past and the current structure
agriculture that is maybe not labeled a
slavery but it's still very unequal yeah
yeah so it's it's no and III agree I and
that's why I bring it up I think I think
we need to have it's something that we
tend to sort of sweep under the rug a
little bit but agriculture is the
primary has been the primary economic
activity associated with slavery or or
sort of unequal treatment and I think
it's good for us to sort of talk about
what serves we're sort of some of the
underlying driving factors associated
with people had slaves basically
linguistic in the ancient world and they
again this is a sequence you you have
ample food production you know think
about an expeditionary force you know
like you can read about it in the
storica document in the scriptures where
armies would go out and they would
capture other people well first of all
you need to be able to sustain an army
which is a logistical challenge even
today and and then you need to bring
those people back and you need to feed
them
and enslave them and and so it was a
very sort of devious sort of set of
actions that sort of created that
situation and you know many millennia
later we actually transported people
across the ocean for the same purpose
and now we you might argue that there's
some issues around the labor that we use
in agriculture this these days right and
that has also to do with the structure
of agriculture that everything has to be
cheap and so this we can talk about that
for I'm not an expert in that area but I
think it is important that we have have
you know that we are honest about that's
part of what we do this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu